[Music]
Hello friends and brothers and sisters
in the Lord and welcome to i' like to
know our Bible question and answer
program here at Su TV and thank you for
joining us
as together we study the word of God my
name is C Murray I'm in the company of
Pastor David Salazar and Pastor Steven
bore uh of this very fine Ministry and
we want to thank you for joining us as
together we go into the word of God and
answer your questions we want to get
right to it if you want your questions
answered if you have a question then we
invite you in the strongest possible
terms to send your question to TV at
some TV sumv
.org that's tvom tv.org we are given to
understand that we're keeping up with
the questions fairly well and we thank
you to keep on sending questions because
without your questions this program is
not possible with your questions all
things are possible and we thank you for
that Pastor Salazar if you would launch
out uh and ask God's blessing upon the
program then we will indeed launch out
and move forward amen let's pray as we
come Lord before for your throne of
grace we come humbly and we thank you
for allowing us to speak with you and to
ask of you this blessing of receiving
the Holy Spirit as we know that in
ourselves we don't have the knowledge or
the understanding but through your Holy
Spirit and the power of your word we may
be able to answer according to your will
so we pray that now you will be with us
give us Clarity of mind and give her
answers the uh the token of your Holy
Spirit so that we may answer according
to your will I pray that you also be
with the audience those that are
watching and hearing may they be blessed
through this program I pray this in
Jesus name amen amen uh the first
question comes to comes to us from
Samson from Ghana and um uh again we
like to encourage you let us know where
the questions are coming from uh it's
not a demand it's just a request because
we like to know where our audiences what
um countries what parts of the world are
watching and consuming our uh our
program I found out Pastor Bor Pastor
Salah just last week that we are very
very popular in the Philippines I did
not know that uh in the southern
Philippines in particular um so you know
it's it's nice to know that you are
reaching out that lives are being
changed people are being blessed around
the world so this is Samson from Ghana
he gives us uh one two three texts
from Exodus 24: 9- 11 going to read them
and then uh his question not a long one
but um it's something that arises from
these text um so Exodus 24 beginning
verse 9 then Moses went up also Aron
naab and Abu and 70 elders of Israel and
they saw the god of Israel and there was
under his feet as it were a paved work
of sapphire stone excuse me and it was
like the very heavens in its
Clarity but on the Nobles of the
children of Israel he did not lay his
hand so they saw God and they ate and
drank the question is given those texts
did they really see God and eat and
drink with
him all right well I'll first I answer
what I believe is happening here first
of all I think verse two uh two of
chapter 24 tells us something about the
experience it says there in verse two of
chapter 24 for the same chapter verse
two says and Moses alone shall come near
the Lord but they shall not come night
neither shall the people go up with him
so he it's uh you know the Lord's
telling him okay Moses come with with
with with your you know with Aaron naat
and ab and the 70 elders but then he
tells him specifically verse two only
you come near NAA NAU and Aaron and the
70 elders are going to stay far away
from me so that is the indication of God
so as as he is coming into the
experience and we see verses 9 through
11 H we we see that you know the Lord
was a figure they actually saw they
actually saw the Lord they saw the
person of of Jesus as he is the one
revealed there and he's the one that
these individuals saw but they didn't
see him very close very near that mean
they were a little farther away
according to verse two uh and then verse
12 then the Lord tells Moses and tells
him to come out uh near him so that he
will give him the tables of stone now as
far as the eating there together they
eat and drink um it's for me at least
it's not very clear that they actually
were eating with with the Lord himself
like in in in like when one table
together but I do believe that they were
they ate and they drank or you know they
were eating in the presence of God in
this in this experence in this
experience where they were near the Lord
but not necessarily close to him as
Moses was this is where from what I can
see from the Bible I don't know
gentlemen what you think about this but
this is what I found I I agree in in the
fact that Moses was summoned and was
allowed to come very close to God to
come proximate to him yeah the Aon n
naab and Bahu were a little further off
um if you look at the I think it's
the I can't I can't remember which Bible
uh uh translation it is it says that
they came close to God but he was still
Shel sheltered and shadowed from them
the text does not say that they ate and
drank with God that that would be a
presumption they the text in several
translations tells that that their lives
were preserved even though they were in
the presence of of God and so if you get
to see an aspect of God and you're still
alive
that's something to eat and drink and be
and celebrate about but but the text
does not say that they ate and drank
with God I think that is presumption
they ate and drank with each other yeah
uh and and possibly because their lives
were were preserved Pastor well I I see
it uh in a much broader
sense um who was the third person that
came to visit Abraham before the cities
of Sodom and Gomorrah were destroyed
one of them was Jehovah Jesus one of
them was Christ and he ate with Abraham
Abraham had a meal prepared for him um
who appeared to to Moses in the burning
bush it was Christ glorified Christ yes
the angel of the Lord he's also called
Michael in the Bible so I believe that
who who appeared there to naab and Abu
and those persons was actually Jesus the
son I can agree with that yeah yes and
and so if they ate there uh you know in
the presence of uh the angel of the Lord
in the presence of Michael whatever has
different names the angel of his
presence uh that would not be an issue
the issue is that John 1:8 says no man
has seen God at any
time the only begotten son which is in
the bosom of the father he has declared
him so nobody has seen the father mhm uh
in fact Ellen White Once
wrote um this is if I if I can find it
here in the book early writings she says
I saw a throne and on it sat the father
and the
son I gazed on Jesus countenance and
admired his lovely person the father's
person I could not
behold for a cloud of Glorious light
covered him I asked asked Jesus if his
father had a form like himself he said
he had but I could not behold it for
said he if you should once Behold The
Glory of his person you would cease to
exist so that person that they saw was
not the was not God the father right it
was the son Jesus Christ Jesus Christ
the lord uh whom Moses encountered in
the burning bush the one who led Israel
in the pillar of cloud and in the pillar
of light in the evenings uh it was Jesus
Christ who is by the way God 100% God
yes but he could be seen in his
pre-incarnate State St State uh so so I
think that that would be uh the the
simplest explanation to this by the way
somebody took Ellen White to task when
uh when she wrote this they wrote back
and said how is it that you saw because
she said I saw a throne and on it sat
the father and the son uh she so how did
you see the father if you saw the father
you would be destroyed she said because
I saw the glory move I assumed that it
was the father inside the glory so that
that's the simplest way that I find to
to solve this issue of them eating with
God seeing God and so on and reconciling
you know the text that says no one has
seen God at any time right and yet it
says here that they see God there has to
be some way of reconciling those two
texts of course of
course all right I like that um um I
dare not read into the the Bible more
than is there so it is not is not stated
per se but that answer certainly gives
us reason and rationale for the way this
text is constructed so well done well
done uh thank you um Samson from from
Ghana I like that name Samson yeah yeah
wonderful name very strong name that's
right converted Samson indeed this is
Kathy now coming to us from Northern
California so a
local in Genesis uh chapter 19:8 lot
offers to give his two virgin daughters
that live at home with him to the men of
Sodom to do as they wish to them not
wanting them to harm the two strangers
so SL angels in his home doesn't that
does that doesn't make sense that he
would offer his children I have not seen
any comments from Ellen White about why
he would put his own daughters in this
situation can you please explain why he
did this is there a logical explanation
for
this the one thing I would say before I
open it up to you worthy gentlemen is
that
um you can't ask for a logical explan
for something that is illogical right it
is an illogical situation amen but lot
had sort of and you know this this is an
a an example of how gracious God is you
know lot chose to pitch his tent towards
Sodom uh so his relationship with the
Lord was not complete but two times we
we find that the Lord reaches out to
save him one he drags him back in the
house and men were going to attack him
and then the next morning when they're
leaving the city the Lord had to push
him along you know he had to push him
along so God is very very merciful to
him this offering of his daughter says
something to me but before I go into do
that I'll I'll let you guys sort of take
a swing in oh I think I want to hear
what you have to say okay I one of the
things I have to say is it it gives you
the the status or lack of status that
women held in that in that era in that
time two the relationship between lot
and his daughters was somewhat suspect
because um later on the moabites and the
ammonites came out of their relationship
with their father um so there's
something incomplete here something that
is for one of the term off-kilter but in
this relationship but it starts with the
fact that lot chose to move into a place
where he's going to be surrounded by sin
and I think the Bible is telling us that
the the sin of that city was getting
into his life into his head into his
heart it certainly got into his wife's
head and heart so there's a there's a a
Continuum here a pattern here of of you
know playing with sin getting close to
sin and trying not to let it affect you
but it does affect you when you when you
toy with it another thing uh adding to
what you're mentioning Pastor CA is that
there was a sense of Duty of hospitality
that especially in that time in that
culture was very strong and uh it was a
sense that you had to protect the guest
that came under your roof even you know
with your own life and not that this is
an excuse for what lot necessarily did
as we can as you will mentioned is
probably his maybe wrong reasoning in a
sense but if we look at the verse at
text he actually first comes and begs
the men not to do this wicked act
because they wanted to carnally know
this man they wanted to abuse you know
rape this man or you know these angels
rather and so they were determined to do
that he comes out and begs them and says
look please don't do this evil act and
then he he uses not that he right but he
uses his human reasoning to say look I
have two virgin daughters do with them
as you please but let my guest because
under the duty of Hospital Hospitality
he was responsible for their well-being
so not to say that again that what he
act was right he just uh lacked the
faith in in the power of God in in a
sense at that moment but uh he was more
concerned of fulfilling that Duty and
that honor of protecting your guest at
all cost and he was willing to sacrifice
even what was dearest to him so again
it's not that he was making the right
decision we're obviously not according
no you know don't believe that way but
it what prompt him to say that was the
sense of obligation he had for his
guests under his roof that's what really
ProMed him to say that not that he was
um trying to somehow allow the daughters
to to be abused that way I have a strong
suspicion
that lot knew that they would not be
interested in his
daughters because he knew of their mob
mentality yes they wanted their way they
wanted to have sexual relations with
those two angels that were in his house
that was their focus and I think that he
just said that as a side comment but he
knew that they were not going to be
satisfied until they had sexual
relations with those two angels that
were in his house having said that lot
was a righteous man mhm he had not
become defiled with the practices of
Sodom but at the same time he was had a
weak character in the sense that he did
not lead his family in the way that God
wanted him to lead them uh the Bible
itself in second Peter chap 2: 7 to9 uh
speaks about lot and it uses the word
righteous I think uh three times to
describe him it says and delivered
righteous lot who was oppressed by the
oppressed by the filthy conduct of the
wicked for that righteous man dwelling
among them tormented yeah his righteous
soul from day to day by seeing and
hearing their Lawless Deeds also he
probably knew that his his daughters had
been influenced by
uh the condition of the city and that
and that they were perhaps beyond the
point of no return too uh let me read
you this statement from Ellen White
Patriarchs and Prophets
168 uh this is where Abraham and lot
make the choice of where they're going
to settle leaving Abraham's Altar and
its daily sacrifice to the Living God he
had permitted his children to mingle
with a corrupt and idolatrous
people yet he had retained in his heart
the fear of God for he is declared in
the scriptures to have been a just man
his righteous Soul was vexed with the
vile conversation that greeted his ears
daily and the violence and crime he was
powerless to prevent he was saved at
last as a brand plucked out of the fire
mhm but then she speaks of the
consequences of his wrong choice yet
stripped of his possession
bered of his wife and children dwelling
in caves like the wild beasts covered
with infamy in his old age and he gave
to the world not a race of righteous men
but two idolatrous Nations yeah at
enmity with God and Waring upon his
people until their cup of iniquity being
full they were appointed to to to
destruction how terrible were the
results that followed one on wise steps
MH uh step so so uh he was a righteous
man but he did not have the
determination to lead his family in the
ways of the Lord but my suspicion is
that he knew that those men were not
interested in his daughters yeah he he
he knew very well that they were focused
on those two men in his house yeah you
know it's interesting because as as I I
said before it it's good that you
brought the balance that he was a
righteous man but
um the moabites and the ammonites came
from both of those girls with their
father yep um he didn't have I use the
term for one of a better one backbone to
resist you know if if you're going to
play with fire you're going to get
burned you're going to push yourself
towards Sodom you may be able to resist
but then it comes up on on on your
family uh your daughters and and of
course your wife we look at the the the
the the case of Eli who had Hof in finia
wouldn't correct them just wouldn't and
they were blatantly doing things in the
temple he wouldn't correct them he the
Bible doesn't say well he was he was not
just but he wouldn't discipline his kids
right uh so sometimes your your laxity
uh is not played out in your life played
out in the lives of your children right
and so we see that he had the backbone
of a jellyfish um you know basically uh
you have an illustration of this in the
story of
Reuben when his brothers took Joseph you
know they put him in the sistern and uh
he said don't kill him don't kill him he
was planning on coming and releasing him
later on yes but meanwhile the
ishmaelites came and he was sold as a
slave to Egypt because Ruben didn't
stand up and say what you're doing is
wrong this is our brother and he should
have sent him home but he didn't have
the backbone he was personally he was
probably okay but uh he didn't have the
determination to call uh sin By Its
Right name yeah you know interestingly
enough though this act of
lot this very Act of him coming before
you know this mob and telling them that
not to do the act so wicked act that
they wanted to do upon the guests and
him even offering his daughters this
first of all proved that he was a
righteous man in the sense that he
reproached them for that vile act they
were trying to do he was trying he you
know and and trying to appease them he
tried to give them an option however
they were so upset at him trying to act
you know more righteous than them that
they were about to jump and destroy him
to pieces as says that and it was then
that the Lord intervened through the
angels and they were struck with you
know blindness so that they could not
find the door and so it was Lot was
saved at that moment by the Angels
because sometimes I would think you you
know why would the Angels not hit these
men with blindness before that's my
question I the same thing you know at
what point did and forgive me pastor at
what point did did lot know if he did
know that he was dealing with angels so
maybe in his mind it was the lesser of
two evils I can't let these people
handle his angels but by the same token
if you if you have full faith let the
Angels take care of it rather than
offering your daughters but you know and
but at the same time we see that you
know that he at least you know proved
that he wanted to s acfic himself before
they would harm the man of God and it
shows that the Lord you know pulled him
out of that experience and save him and
save his his daughters at the end of the
day you know you know his family so it
it shows us that you know he was a
righteous man maybe weak in many in some
ways but at the same time he tried to do
what he wanted to do his best for for
for the sake of the guest that he had in
his house this idea of commanding your
household after you is lorded in the
Bible mhm it is one thing to have
personal Integrity but when when you
have to stand up and leave your house
your wife your children your in-laws um
we see that there are times when men
fail uh they have a personal Integrity
but they're not quite able to gather
enough spiritual strength to get that
family line to follow and there are
consequences that acre from that that
kind of action you know and that's the
reason why uh when the Bible speaks
about the qualifications of the Elder
yes or the pastor of the church mhm
which is male because the man is the
head of the household he's the
disciplinarian he's the one that is
supposed to have his children in
submission according to the Bible uh
that flows over into the church yes the
man in the church should exercise that
over the larger family which is the
church family and one of the
qualifications that is presented in the
New Testament is that he should have his
children in submission MH and that's
what lot lacked uh and that's what many
households lack is that the the husband
is not exercising his leadership role I
dare I even use the word headship role
in the church in in the church and at
home yeah I've seen many many times the
the father and mother in the church uh
sitting down reading the Bible praising
the Lord and the children are outside
just teing a place apart you know and no
one's looking after them nobody's
babysitting no one's correcting them uh
that that that speaks against your
standing in the church that you're not
commanding your household after them
which is a Biblical imperative and the
result is that the home is a
disaster and the children eventually go
astray and the church is a disaster
because we don't follow God's counsel in
uh Timothy and Titus about uh the male
being the leadership in the church we
allow culture
to dictate what we do rather than simply
taking the Bible as it reads and doing
what the Bible says God's plan is always
the best plan let's not allow culture to
dictate what we decide to do yeah the
family of of the experience of lot shows
us the danger of allowing culture to
dictate or to influence your family in
the thinking and reasoning and we see it
over and over again I remember CD Brooks
used to say the ethic ought not suffer
under the weight of the ethnic you
know very good he had a away with words
he did he did well again our time has
slipped into eternity allow me in
closing to wish you Grace and peace
through our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
we'll see you again soon byebye and God
bless
[Music]